well Josh Gates the host of expedition
unknown joins me now uh Josh thank you
very much indeed for joining me you
actually walked away from an opportunity
to film the Titanic down uh where it
lurks in the ocean why was that
well we uh we were thinking about doing
a special on Titanic and uh to work
alongside Stockton and Ocean Gate and we
went up to the Ocean Gate headquarters
in Everett Washington in 2021 so this
was just a few months before Ocean Gate
was set to take its first group of
passengers down to the Titanic and we
spent a few days up there and we went
out on Titan in Puget Sound and took it
out for what was effectively a Shakedown
dive getting it ready uh for those uh
operations in the North Atlantic and uh
you know by the end of my time there and
uh I had a real you know a terrific time
working with Stockton I'm absolutely
kind of just beside myself here
listening to all this just kind of
taking it in in real time it's just um
it's a lot to process but by the end of
that experience I just did not feel that
this was for me I I really felt more
than anything that it was nearly
impossible to to measure the risk of
Titan as a platform it was just almost
impossible to measure it against
anything else it is such a unique
vehicle it is a one-off you know there's
nothing else like it and because of that
there's nothing to compare it to and for
me it represented uh frankly just too
much risk and I and it just wasn't for
me in the end do you feel that but for
the grace of God
about this yeah I mean it's yeah you
know um I I knew Stockton and again I I
really am just stunned sitting here
about this news I knew Hamish Harding as
well who's a fellow member of the
Explorers Club an incredible individual
um a big figure both inside and outside
the club and and um
yeah I mean I'm beside myself there's
something uh I just sit here listening
to this news and remember my time in
Titan remember going down I spent
probably two or three hours in the sub
with with Stockton taking its through
its paces and and uh
you know I think like everybody I just
prayed right up until that conference
for yeah a miracle for a positive
outcome to all this uh Titanic film
director James Cameron currently
speaking to ABC News in America has just
said I'm struck by the similarity of the
Titanic disaster itself where the
captain was repeatedly warned about ice
ahead of his ship and yet he steamed at
full speed into an ice field
yeah I mean
listen this is a really difficult moment
I think for the families of these
individuals I I don't share some of the
viewpoints of your of um of the
gentleman Fred who was on a few moments
ago what I do share is this really
strong belief that the passengers aboard
Titan were incredibly uh courageous
individuals uh you know I've really been
sickened by so much of the especially on
social media so many people commenting
why would you do this why would you put
your life at risk to go down there and I
have to say that you know
um look Titanic has fascinated the world
since the night that she sank and it
holds a deep personal meaning for many
people shipwrecks in general as someone
who's visited many shipwrecks uh in my
career shipwrecks are time capsules they
connect us to the Past in a really
intimate way and there are people uh I
mean look at pH nargely his entire
career had been devoted uh after his
work in the Navy to studying Titanic and
to being one of the world's foremost
experts on this ship this is something
that held great meaning for these people
and so uh you know as someone who went
in Titan and and really didn't feel like
I was comfortable going down to those
depths in it I have to say it takes an
enormous amount of determination of
Courage of fortitude to take any trip
inside a submersible Titan or otherwise
uh and so I think there should be a huge
amount of admiration for all those
people yeah that's for Stockton I I have
to say you know I really really admire
his vision I admire his Spirit of
innovation I admire that he was a risk
taker in some ways I do think there are
still really important questions to ask
not today but soon uh about his
calculations of risk and acceptable risk
and and again I don't think that's
something for today but I I do think
that he was an innovator he was someone
who was trying to create a new
um a new platform that could open up uh
the depths of the ocean to to more
people I think that is a commendable
Noble aim I think there are big
questions about how he got there and I
think that there'll be a time for that
but as for today I I just remain so
heartbroken for the families of these
people and for the passengers all of
them
um because I do think as an Explorer as
a guy who who understands people's
passions for things like this
um it was an admirable goal to go down
there and hey Miss Harding an
extraordinary guy he's a British
billionaire 58 years old he's chairman
of a dubai-based private plane firm
action Aviation but he holds three
Guinness world records including the
longest duration of full ocean depth by
crude vessel when he in March 2021 and
Ocean Explorer Victor vescovo dived to
the lowest part of the Mariana Trench he
was also Mission director and crew pilot
for the flight mission one more orbit
which set the current world speed record
for the fastest circumnavigation of
Earth by aircraft over both Geographic
polls I mean they're quite extraordinary
Adventurer and Explorer and you know are
there many people who are billionaires
who would risk everything to go down to
the bottom of the ocean to see the wreck
of the Titanic I doubt it and there are
something Richard Branson is one that
Springs to mind who who has done that
kind of thing but there are many most of
them Bank their cash and sit somewhere
you know surrounded by comfort and
security this guy risked his life and
yes he lost his life doing it but he was
in his bones an Explorer an adventurer a
risk taker probably made him the success
he was and I think that that's why I
totally concur with you that when people
ask why did they do this well why does
anyone do anything out of the ordinary
why does anyone go you know there are
people who who climb K2 right I'm not
going to climb K2 that's not for me but
I wouldn't say that someone was crazy to
do it because whether it's
mountaineering whether it's deep sea
exploration whether it's you know
anything if it holds great personal
meaning to you
then it's something that's admirable for
you to do you know and and so I I think
these people were incredibly Brave
Josh I really appreciate you joining me
thank you very much indeed
thank you pierce